localized hyperthermia, heat,
versus intratumeral immutal therapy,
freezee, what are your thoughts about each and could you recommend it?
So cryotherapy for tubers, or hypertherapy for tubers,
both work, both have the ability to work,
because whenever you're drastically changing the temperature of the cell,
the cell could die.
So if you drastically change the temperature higher,
the cell could die lower, the cell could die.
And cancer cells are going to be more susceptible to death than healthy cells.
So if I could drastically increase or decrease or cold on a group of cells,
some of them are healthy cells and some of them are cancer cells,
you have a greater chance of killing the cancer cell.
Either way, both of them work.